toutes les versions du couple parfait
sur tf6 qui prend effet pour une pole
d'audience 6014 c'est la cata et on a vu
du go un des candidats qui s'est
ramassés pendant la cérémonie jusqu'à
une cérémonie jamais regardé l'émission
ça c'était bien l'été et c'est vrai que
là c'est mal programmées et ça prend des
tôles d'audience et c'est vrai que bon
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit la sarre
a choisi provost ego vient de rejoindre
vous savez ce qui en plus n'est pas le
monsieur rétiaire il aurait pu faire
très très mal un gilet de 10,6 après le
match 3 qui la fait pas trois inconnus
tout va
non mais sans déconner c'est bon c'est
bon on l'a vu sa foi n'a pas tout mais
quand on paie 10 fois jusqu'à b6 ouf ça
rigolait le pot ça fait de la peine de
mort c'est sûr heureusement qui s'est
passé ça pour qu'on parle de l'émission
l'émission il a failli air annonce que
c'est ce qui me fait de la peine c'est
de voir qu'elle a fire la peau hâlée
chercheur alain quinet thank you and i
mais c'est vrai quand même superbe après
les huit ans que je suis là je voulais
la prendre sur est adorable
ah oui ouais bah non alors au nom mais
on se perd de valérie benaïm je trouve
que franchement j'adore elsa là-bas
aussi il adore mais elle mérite beaucoup
mieux fait d une mort hier sur tf1 bam
on l'appelle point de télé-réalité
machin bayavuge haut perchée c'est vrai
que ces dix couples d'amis c'est ma tu
connais la phrase dont gérer une
carrière c'est savoir dire non je vous
proposais un truc mouais eh ben dites
moi non la fin de l'année ça